the verdict is in and it looks as though
Hollywood's ill-fated quest to adapt an
anime into a successful live-action
feature is set to stumble on Netflix was
always taking a chance by remaking a
property held in such high regard by
anime fans both at home in Japan and
around the world and sadly their
english-language us-based take on the
anime classic Death Note this completely
failed to take off here's why trying too
hard the smash success of stranger
things on Netflix recently led to a
burst of 80s nostalgia in film and
television and Death Note shamelessly
hits us a ride on that particular
bandwagon the film even employs the
classic almost cliched slow-mo opening
scene reminiscent of the famous
head-over-heels high school scene from
the indie classic Donnie Darko Berlin's
take my breath away and air supply's
version of the power of love both show
up of course albeit only in what amounts
to little more than a shallow attempt to
cultivate style in the absence of any
real substance a horror director by
trait death notes director Adam Wingard
dabbled in his 80s odd house aesthetics
for his 2014 thriller hybrid the guest
the death note borrows just a little too
heavily from the dark neon hues of films
like drive and cold in July the screen
the casting of former Nickelodeon star
NAT Wolff as leading man like Turner was
an uninspired one the actors performance
has been one of the main sticking points
for fans of the original anime with one
scene in particular often singled out
for ridicule when death god Ryu first
reveals himself to light he does so with
an impressive display of his powers
wolf's reaction is well let's just say
it's attracted some understandable
criticism
not exactly in keeping with the mangas
iSchool version of the character white
life but that wasn't the film's only
problem with death nartz protagonist
white is such an interesting character
to follow in the manga and anime because
he isn't just some kid who's come across
a book that can kill people is also an
immensely clever sociopath who relishes
the chance to use the death NART
and keeps its existence completely
secret for that very reason
Netflix's light is neither a genius nor
sociopath and only ends up becoming Kira
because he's pushed down the path of
darkness by other characters with the
genders of their own not because of the
dark aspects of his own character is
that what we're gonna do with the note
liked rules and warnings reuse purpose
to keep light as innocent as possible in
all this the filmmakers needed to shift
the blame for the plots death and
destruction on to someone else and Ryu
must have been a natural choice of
scapegoat White's girlfriend Muir
certainly plays her part in convincing
him to go crazy with the north but the
death God is painted as the true
instigator of the chaos which takes
place in the Netflix remake he's the one
who convinced his light to commit his
very first murder and he continues to
manipulate him from there on in in the
original Death Note
however reacts role is not to press a
lot into using the note but to simply
tag along
mostly because he's bored and finds
slights behavior interesting
a quick note at a hundred minutes when
God's film wasn't much longer than your
typical horror or comedy flick and
constituted far too short a time span to
do the detailed source material any kind
of justice these constraints meant that
certain vital plot points had to be
abandoned and relationships fast-tracked
the result being a movie that felt
completely rushed Death Note is not
light reading
after all there's a reason that Japanese
live-action version was split into two
separate films and even they had to skip
certain elements of the manga in the end
it might have served the Netflix version
better to have been produced as an
gentle series played out over ten hour
long episodes this problem with the
remake was best summed up in a review by
the LA Times shortly after death night's
debut it said for a film ten years in
the making that show up feels like
everyone involved is in a hurry to get
it over with
forcing love another character who
barely resembles the version on which
they were based is MIA who is turned
from an innocent bystander
into a genuine monster for the remake
when guards Death Note painter is
totally unhinged and entirely willing to
manipulate light into using the Death
Note without a second thought for the
repercussions
Netflix's Death Note also turned Mia and
light into some kind of tragic love
story when in the source material their
relationship was anything but
again this seems like an attempt to
shoehorn Hollywood storytelling
conventions into a story which only
succeeded by getting rid of them in the
first place in the real death narc the
only thing light ever falls in love with
is power